wildfires rage in Indonesia floods sweep
through southern Germany the effects of
climate change are evident all over the
world at Deutsche Welle global media
forum and bond journalists politicians
and climate experts have gathered to
discuss ways to implement the Paris
climate agreement and how the media can
help sink the medium isn't some line I
think the media has to explain just what
climate change is there's still a big
knowledge gap the media should clarify
what an energy supply transformation
might look like in every country on
Earth one example is eco at Africa an
interactive TV program produced by DW in
cooperation with channels TV in Nigeria
the show focuses on success stories like
that of bilitis adebiyi abiola her
company we cyclers helps ease the
massive garbage problem in lagos and
offers money-making incentives at the
same time locals who separate their
trash are awarded in a point system
which enables them to obtain kitchen
appliances or cash but Billy cos adebiyi
abiola says Europe should play a role in
Africa's sustainable development a lot
of multinationals operating in countries
like Nigeria come from countries like
Germany like in the in the EU and they
need to put the same standards the same
practices that they are on there in
Germany and in their countries in the
countries they are working in and what
does that mean that means that they need
to conform with helping to clean up
communities they need to pay for
ensuring that the waste products are
cleaned up in the community that the
operating are not only in their home
countries Deutsche Welle global media
forum brings activists like Billy casada
be a viola together with decision makers
from Europe real change requires
everyone to join in